foreign
and today I'm going to be talking about
vertex sparsification for Edge
connectivity in polynomial time
to start let me introduce the problem of
vertex varsification more generally
the problem of vertex sparsification is
asks given a graph G
which has vertices V and edges e and
some terminals T which are a subset of
the vertices
the goal is to find a smaller graph H
that also contains those terminals T
that approximately preserves some
property amongst vertices in t
this property that can be preserved can
be several things
examples that have been studied in the
past include spectral vertex parsifiers
also known as sure complement some
graphs and these objects preserve
electrical properties between the
vertices in the terminals at T
blow as far as location asks to preserve
multi-commodity flows where the demands
are supported on the terminal set t
and cut sparsification asks to maintain
Edge connectivity between subsets of the
terminals t
the goal of a Vertex varsification
problem is to prove that you can
construct a graph h
whose size depends only on T and the
smaller the dependence on the size of T
the better
throughout this talk we're going to let
K denote the size of t
in this talk we're going to be focusing
on vertex verification for Edge
connectivity so let me just formalize
that problem yeah
in vertex minus pH for Edge connectivity
we want to preserve the Min cut in the
graph G between S and T minus s for any
subset s so for any partition of the
terminal
set into a subset S and T minus s you
want to preserve the Min cut in some way
the Min cut here is defined as between S
and T minus s is defined as the minimum
over cuts in the original graph G whose
restriction to the terminosity is just S
and T minus s
it's the Min over
all a intersect T equals s of the number
of edges between A and B minus a in the
original graph
a mimicking Network
is defined as a graph H that preserves
this cut exactly
what's known about mimicking mimicking
networks is that the size of H is almost
2 to the 2 to the K so doubly
exponential in the number of terminals
and it's not that there exists graphs G
where the number of vertices in each has
to be at least two to the K but nothing
really is known about closing this Gap
if you ask for approximate Notions I
just want to maintain every cut to one
plus Epsilon Factor
um very little is known in general no
lower bounds are really known that are
better than linear and K and upper
bounds I don't know of anything really
better than exponential or doubly
exponential
so it's a kind of wide open problem
in this work we focus on the problem of
C Edge connectivity
this is actually a more restrictive
version than even the OnePlus Epson a
fox
so here we should think of C equals
something like 10 like a small constant
and the goal is to construct a graph H
that preserves Min Cuts exactly
as long as they're in most C
in other words we want to preserve the
value of Min of c and the mincom so we
want to preserve small connectivities
and the connectivities are large we
don't really care
let me just give a little bit of broader
motivation for why study vertex
classification in general
in general designing vertex modification
and efficient algorithms for
constructing the vertex parts of fires
it leads to efficient graph algorithms
for a variety of problems
efficient algorithms for constructing
sugar complements have led to very
beautiful and simple laplacian solving
Frameworks as well as data structures
for dynamic electrical flows
vertex Sparks virus for lengths and cuts
have given Dynamic data structures for
transshipment and Max flows
approximately
along these lines
recent Works have used C Edge
connectivity mimicking networks as
defined on the previous slide to give
Dynamic care YC Edge connectivity in m
to the little o of one amortized time
for constants C so we Sorry C equals 10
we can add edges to a graph delete edges
to the graph and query C Edge
connectivities and amortized m to the
level of one time
additionally vertex sparsifiers for sea
Edge connectivity
can be used to solve the subset c Edge
connectivity problem which is to find
the smallest cost subgraph that makes
all pairs of terminals in C and T C
connected
another point I wanted to discuss about
sea Edge connectivity vertex parsifiers
is why is it important that we want to
maintain the Min cut between all
partitions S and T minus S as opposed to
the Min cut just between Pairs of
terminals
all right
the critical reason is because of the
following lever
if H is a c connectivity mimicking
network of G
and we add an edge between a pair of
terminals
then H is
still a c Edge connectivity making
network of G as long as we add the edge
e in so H with the edge e added is a c
connectivity maybe a network of G with
the edge e added
this is not true for the paradise
definition the intuition is that
um
a pair of vertices might have several
Min cuts and if you just preserve one of
them in Cuts then adding this Edge it
could cross that one Min cut that we're
seeing and then the size goes up
so that's really the big reason why we
study
I'm maintaining the connectivity between
S and T minus s for all subsets S as
opposed to just pairwise
in particular for the dynamic data
structure design it is important to work
with
the all subsets definition because you
want to dynamically begin to the graph H
so uh when G undergoes an edge insertion
between terminals then we can update the
efficient update H efficiently just by
adding in the edgy itself
now let me State uh the results of this
work
previous works I've given C Edge
connectivity mimicking networks with K
times C to the fourth edges and they
were constructed in time m c log n to
the ofc
our results construct mimicking networks
with KC cubed edges so less edges or KC
cubed times poly log number of edges in
randomized polynomial time
so notice that if C is at least log K or
log n then the previous Works did not
run in polynomial time however our
algorithm does run up regardless of the
value of C
and it's worth noting that the results
of this work have been extended to
hypergraph settings
before going on into the proof let me
just State a couple of future directions
that I find to be very interesting
I think the most important future
directions are to improve the runtime to
M times policy the runtime of this work
is just polynomial in the number of
edges just poly M but I think M times
poly C would be a big deal because
that's kind of linear and polynomial and
C
and optimistically if that algorithm
could be made Dynamic then you could get
Dynamic C Edge connectivity and
amortized o tilde policy time
this would greatly improve over the
current bounds which are m to the poly c
times little of one so it's m to the
little o of one and then the exponent
has a polynomial dependency
so it would really be a big Improvement
if this all went through but currently
the runtime of the algorithm presented
in this work is just polynomial number
of edges
now let me go over the proof
the first step in the proof is to reduce
to the case where all terminals have
degree one
we do this at the cost of increasing the
number of terminals by a factor of C so
this accounts for one of our three
factors of C our bonus is KC cubed
um
basically the way this is done is you
assume that every terminal has degree
and most C because we can only care
about C Edge connectivities
then if a terminal has some numbered
edges out of it you kind of just treat
each of those edges itself as a terminal
and at uh so what happens is the number
of terminals now has gone up by a factor
of C but now all the terminals have
degree one
our main level is that if all terminals
have degree one then we construct a c
Edge connectivity mimicking network with
size of TC squared edges or so that is c
squared times poly log number in
polynomial time
this implies our main result of this
work which is K times C cubed edges in
the making Network because we've
increased the number of terminals by a
factor of C
the proof of this main claim has two
steps
the first step is to use ideas from
Metroid Theory or representative sets of
metroids to show a bound of t c c plus d
where D is the largest number of
vertices
uh number of terminals on the smaller
side of a Min cut with
of size of OC so here it's like oh Max
over the Min cut between S and T minus s
in the graph G A Moc of the smaller of
the two sides
now our goal is going to be to reduce
the value of d by partitioning the graph
we're going to reduce to the case where
D is ofc
or D is ofc times poly log n by using a
source cut algorithm so the D is O of C
bound can be done existentially but not
efficiently
uh but we can
uh reduce to a case where D is ofc poly
log n by calling US forces cut algorithm
and that can be the efficient
let me start by discussing the second
part the recursive partitioning so how
do we reduce this value of D which is as
a reminder it's the larger num uh it's
the largest possible value of the number
of terminals on the smaller side of a
small cut
to recursively partition the graph we
require the following level
given a graph G what some vertices V and
edges e
um and some subset a of the original F
so a is subset of B
and terminals T we want to par where we
if you partition the graph g into a and
v minus a
and then you add some terminals uh you
add all endpoints of the cut edges as
terminals
then if we recursed on the vertices a
and v minus a separately built mimicking
that works for them
and then took their Union Plus all the
cut edges then we'll have a mimicking
network of the whole graph
so that's a lot let me try to give an
example
let's consider the following graph with
four terminals marked in red
this graph has a sparse cut so let's
imagine partitioning the graph along as
far as cut into two halves
there's one cut Edge and we want to add
both the endpoints of the cut Edge as
terminals
now we have two separate sides each with
three terminals
we're going to recurse on both halves
and build American Network on both of
them the way it's done you can just turn
into a triangle
now you add back in the cut Edge and you
can show that this resulting graph is a
mimicking network of the original graph
okay
so now the algorithm is in general going
to be simple we're going to find a
sparse cut for some definition of sparse
you know partition the graph along that
scarce cut add in the add in the
endpoints of the cut edges as Terminals
and just recurse until we can anymore
the definition of Response Code we're
going to use is that while there exists
and where while there exists a cut a B
minus a with the most C edges and the
number of terminals on the smaller side
is at least three times C then we're
going to partition along that cut and
then recurse on both sides
it is easy to show that if you do this
then when we're finished with the
procedure at most oft total terminals
will have been added to the graph so
there's still oft trembles on the graph
now we just build the mimicky network on
all the subgraphs and hence we've
reduced to the case where D is almost 3C
now this is inefficient because it's
unclear how to check whether there's a
set a with no C cut edges and the
smaller side has size at least
um 3C
to do this efficiently we're going to
use a sparse this kind of algorithm to
get an approximation for our
partitioning
the algorithm is going to undergo a
small change while there exists a set a
such as the ratio of the smaller side to
the number of cut edges is at least C
Times log n to the three halves we do a
partition along a B minus a add uh the
endpoints of eav minus a s Terminals and
recurse on the sub graphs
so if there exists such a sparse cut
then you can use a root login source
code approximation algorithm to find an
a
um where the
the smart see the cut is at least a
login instead of log into the three
halves
and you can prove that if you partition
recursively
uh with cut status Varsity log n then
there's the most oft total terminals at
the end of the procedure
and uh through this we reduce the case
where D is almost C Times log n to the
three halves
so now that we've finished the recursive
partitioning scheme
um the next part to discuss is how to
prove a bound of O of T times c times C
plus d once again D is the number of
terminals on the smaller side of a small
cut
we're going to do this with metroids and
representative sets but it's still used
to set up some kind of framework to
apply this with
we're going to call an edge essential if
Contracting The Edge e affects some Min
cut more precisely we call an edgy
essential if for some cut s some subset
s
the Min cut between S and T minus s goes
up
when we contract The Edge e in the graph
this is equivalent to saying that the
edge e is in every s t minus s Min cut
for some subset s
it suffices to show that there's a most
o of T times c times C plus d essential
edges
um the reason being that if there's some
Edge e that's not essential you can just
contract it and it's obviously a c Edge
connectivity
mimicking Network
um so you keep Contracting edges that
are not essential until all the edges
are essential
so if we were able to show that there's
a most T times c times C plus d Central
edges
so we're going to use metroids and
representatives that's to show this
bound on the number of essential edges
for the purposes of this talk we can
think of a Metroid as just uh Matrix is
an object whose ground elements are
vectors over some finite field
and independent sets in the matroid are
just collections of vectors that are
linearly independent
for a Metroid M and some collection of
Independence that's I we say that a sub
collection I star is a representative
set for I if
for all independence that's X
such that there exists a y and I that is
disjoint from X and X Union Y is
independent in M then there must exist a
y Prime and I star that has the same
property it's destroying for x and x
Union y Prime is independent in m
a classical theorem of lovas and um more
recently Marx
says that if m is a direct sum Metroid
and all the Mis are representable over
some finite field meaning that they can
be represented as vectors and linear
Independence and Mi has a ground set s i
and I is a subset of um is an
independent is a collection of
Independence X which is just a subset of
picking one element
um in the ground side of each Metroid
then we can find an i star uh that's a
representative set
whose size the most the product of the
ranks
while I'm not going to give the details
for how to apply this um I'm at least
going to stay kind of intuitively what's
going on
the idea is that we construct a Metroid
M which is the direct sum of three
metroids
the idea is that M1 encodes the cut
edges
M2 encodes the terminals that are on the
larger side of the cut
and M3 encodes the terminals that are on
the smaller side of the cut
the key claim is that in this
Construction
an edge e must be in the representative
set I star if the edgy is essential
thus by the previous theorem the size of
I star is in most the product of the
ranks which is almost c times K times d
the rank of M1 is Moc because M1
includes the cut edges which there's the
most C of them
M2 is the totals on the larger side of
the cut which is the most k
and M3 encodes the terminals on the
smaller side of the cut which there's a
Bose d
um so we get a bound of c times the
number of terminals times d
the reason our final round differs a
little bit from this is to formalize
this you must actually work with vertex
Cuts instead of edge cuts because vertex
Cuts end up more naturally corresponding
to certain metroids called the gamoids
and that's the Matrix we actually use in
the construction piece
to wrap up this word gives C Edge
connectivity maybe he networks with KC
cubed edges or KC cubed times polylog
edges in randomized polynomial time
if she's at least long end this improves
over KC cubed
um which ran in M times C log into the
ox C time which would not have been
called real time for large values of c
the algorithm has two main steps we
first recursively partition to reduce
the smaller side of the small cuts
this is efficient up to polylog factor
losses due to sparse's cut approximation
algorithms
and in the second step we open up the
Metroid Theory or representative sets
constructions to achieve a smaller
mimicking Network when the smallest head
is guaranteed to only have a few
vertices
the main open problems are improving the
runtime to M times policy or
dynamicizing that construction
to give better Dynamic algorithms for C
Edge connectivity
and yeah that's the talk